- Any opportunity to get drunk
in the morning is a good time for me.
- Yes, the early turnup is what matters.
- What?
I actually don't drink in the morning.
- Steven goes home on a Friday
evening and just curls up in bed.
(laughs)
- That's correct.
- [Curly] You gotta live life.
(upbeat techno music)
- Today we're going to get brunch.
- For me, brunch is that last bit of space
in the weekend where you can get
that last little smidge of fun.
(ding)
(pop)
- Brunch is literally my
favorite thing in life.
(ding)
(pop)
What kind of bunch do you usually go to?
- Chinese brunch.
- Chinese brunch is the best.
- [Curly] That sounds good.
I've never been to Chinese brunch though.
- Me neither.
(ding)
(pop)
(cheerful band music)
- [Freddie] Let's go, guys.
- [Steven] Let's go, let's get outta here.
(woos)
We're goin' to the San Gabriel Valley.
- Are you?
Do you ever go to the San Gabriel Valley?
What?
(laughs)
- Hot box.
- [Steven] There might not
be AC, I don't think
there is AC in this place.
- No AC or booze
is my favorite.
- [Freddie] I'm thinking no
AC, no booze, and really far out.
This has to be super authentic.
- [Steven] We're at our
first place for brunch.
Huge Tree Pastry.
What is your first impression of this?
- [Curly] I think it looks beautiful.
- I think this looks really exciting.
- [Steven] It's called
Fan Tuan in Mandarin.
(ding)
- [Curly] Holy shit, yes.
- Yeah, this rice casing
is really, really good.
- You kinda taste the
egg, it's a little sweet.
I like the texture of the rice
'cause the rice is a little harder.
- A little bit.
It's like a reverse burrito.
This is my childhood, right?
You take it and dip it in the soy milk.
- [Freddie] Whoa.
- Mmm.
- It's like a churro and a funnel cake
made a baby and that's the baby.
- Beef noodle soup.
♫ Beef noodle soup ♫
- [Freddie] I picture
myself in the winter though,
sitting by a fire eating this.
My favorite was that first
little number we had.
- Was it Fun Tuan?
'Cause it was a lot of fun.
- Yeah.
- My idea of brunch is just family time.
- [Curly] You're so sweet.
- Mom and dad and your siblings
that you don't see all week.
- This is why you have a
girlfriend and I'm single.
(laughs)
- What's next on our agenda?
- I think your place.
- My place?
All right.
(upbeat electronica music)
- This is the Village Idiot.
You mainly come just to get drinks
and chat and catch up on the weekends,
but a lot of times we'll
get the banana bread
or the pancakes, so I am
going to share some seafood
with my friends and some tasty drinks.
- I don't drink, but because I'm here,
Freddie, I'll make an exception for you.
- And I do drink, so let's do this.
- Woo!
- Brunch is a very impromptu thing.
We try and get cute but
it's a lived-in cute
'cause we're still--
- [Curly] 'Cause you're still
cute.
- [Freddie] Yeah.
- The lemon chelada looks good.
Something that I love about this place
is that the seafood is sustainable.
- [Curly] It's so good.
It's a little buttery...
- [Freddie] It kinda just slides on down.
- And now they really care
about the fish, right?
- I'm stoked.
- Here's how we'll do
this, I'll get one piece.
- Go ahead, Papa.
- And you guys share this piece.
- It's so good, I mean...
- Is that how we're doin' things?
- He's drunk, leave him alone, he's drunk.
- Okay, he's drunk, yeah.
- Look at all the wine I've had.
One more question, have you ever met
the man of your dreams at a brunch?
- I have never met the man
of my dreams at a brunch.
- We're gonna throw her in the kitchen
and see what she finds in there.
(laughs)
- What's next, we're heading
to the next spot, Curly?
- All right, guys, we're going to one
of my favorite spots in West Hollywood,
which is Boy Town in LA,
called Hamburger Mary's.
They're known for their
really cool drag shows
and their very super-strong drinks.
They're also known for
their fantastic restrooms
where you can actually
have a party of your own.
(cheerful techno music)
(laughs)
- Now get out 'cause I gotta pee.
Brunch is about, for me, getting a little
tipsy early in the morning, but I think
for the most part it's
about having a breakfast
with your friends, enjoying yourself.
Like I said, I always get the
vodka, just get the job right.
I try not to get too crazy 'cause
I have a full Sunday ahead of me
and I just wanna have a good time.
- Steven has never had a mimosa before.
- What do I expect, Curly?
- Just orange juice with a kick in it.
- Cheers, guys.
- Cheers.
- Oh, we did get sliders today.
If I am gonna eat, I probably wouldn't
eat this whole thing by myself,
but I steal tiny little bites and each
of us can dip in and keep it cute.
- [Steven] This one really
just melts in your mouth.
- [Freddie] Wow.
- And then come over the drag queens,
'cause drag queens are everything.
You literally can be
hearing your favorite tunes,
having your favorite cocktail,
hangin' out with your favorite people,
and having one of the best burgers.
- Good choice.
- Yeah, thanks for bringing us here.
- Not that I doubted your taste.
- I never doubted.
Who knew there were so many
different kinds of brunches?
- I didn't know that people went out
to have breakfast and didn't drink.
- You can really eat anything for brunch.
- So here's to friendship
and good love and good stuff, guys.
- And to brunch.
- [Curly] And to brunch.
- Here's to brunch.
- [Curly] To brunch!
(upbeat electronica music)